The definition I am going to give you is based on.
What I have read?
In a very well-known book called The Princeton companion.
of mathematics
the Princeton companion to mathematics
In that book they say that there's not a clear
distinction.
and it is
debatable as to what constitutes pure mathematics.
and what constitutes a plight mathematics and
why I've
here to overlapping diagrams
But to keep it concise I will give
you this definition.
First mathematics what is mathematics in
its entirety?
One common definition is that mathematics is a language.
Just like English and German and Mandarin our
languages mathematics 2 was a language.
The difference is mathematics is the language.
for expressing ideas, very precisely
Which is not true for other spoken languages.
So just like in English we have vocabulary and
grammar rules.
We have vocabulary and rules in
mathematics.
But it's a language. All right mathematics.
Is a language and of course if you
want you can also say it's a collection of ideas.
Collection are very brilliant ideas, of course all of them
communicated in a language of precision.
What does that mean for applied and pure mathematics? What does it have to do with this
discussion? Well Applied Mathematics is about how
you use that language. It's about
how you use this language?
to solve problems in the real world in the real physical
world whether it is at the
Atomic level
or
in the you know
Cosmic level
whereas pure mathematics is about the language itself
is the study of the language.
So you're not using pure mathematics to?
you know send a rocket to
Mars or at least that's not the direct intention rather
it is to
Define things for example in English.
We might have a debate. What is a noun? What
makes a pronoun what are the rules that award
must follow in
order for it to be considered an adjective? For example?
so
That's really it Applied. Mathematics is how you apply mathematics to
solve a problem.
Like in physics or any of the engineering disciplines
or computer science, whereas pure mathematics is
about mathematics and its rules.
Now again, what does this have to do with?
discrete mathematics or programming
Again, I want to bring you back to what I said at the start of this.
session
there are two obstacles.
to becoming proficient in mathematics
and you know, you don't need to you don't need me to convince you of
this statement that if you are proficient in mathematics, it
can be proficient anything and any
of the mathematical disciplines
whether it's physics.
economics
Data science, you name it?
If you know math.
Then you can do whatever you want.
but most of the time
people have
a sense of urgency about
solving particular problem and learning enough about this
language. We call mathematics to the extent that
allows them to solve the problem.
And they may not be no be too concerned about all of
the symbols and terms and
rules, you know, pedagogical and
philosophical.
concerns
it'll just learn enough for to solve a
particular problem. And this is a specially true for computer programs learn
enough or learn the bare minimum
just to be able to build an application or Implement a
certain algorithm. The problem is when you have this approach.
You will.
Plateau very quickly, you'll you will
make a lot of progress at the very beginning but then
very soon you will.
You will Plateau you will get stuck. You will not be able to go
very far.
And you know, there is a
wealth of information that is produced every
day.
In the form of academic papers about solving
all kinds of complex problems.
Let me say that again.
there is
in Academia a lot of great academic Papers
written
About computer science and machine learning.
but
to the broader Community this information is
not accessible.
And I don't mean it's not hard. It's not easy to get a hold of
such a paper. I mean in the sense that it's not easy for them to read it
and understand it.
because these papers
are
well, you know expressed a lot in mathem is
a lot of mathematics explanation. And if you cannot read the ball,
you won't be able to interpret you will not be able to interpret them. And if
you're not able to interpret them, then you won't be able to implement them.
So, how do you stay ahead? How do you put yourself in
a situation you where you can read any
Type of paper and you know stay ahead.
well
You want to pay more attention?
to the symbols to the rules
so you want to have the mentality of
someone in pure mathematics
if you learn the language early.
It will pay dividends in the future. You'll be
able to progress a lot faster.
Than if you try to stumble along the way
and learn whatever you can along the way.
All right. This is what this session is about and this
is what the course is about.
It is about.
teaching you
the language properly
and teaching you to independently learn the
language going forward.
All right.
That's enough with this section. Let's move on.